we last left off studying the heat
equation in the one-dimensional case of
a rod the question is how the
temperature distribution along such a
rod will tend to change over time and
this gave us a nice first example for a
partial differential equation it told us
that the rate at which the temperature
at a given point changes over time
depends on the second derivative of that
temperature at that point with respect
to space where there's curvature in
space there's change in time here we're
gonna look at how to solve that equation
and actually it's a little misleading to
refer to all of this as solving an
equation the PDE itself only describes
one out of three constraints that our
temperature function must satisfy if
it's gonna accurately describe heat flow
it must also satisfy certain boundary
conditions which is something we'll talk
about momentarily and a certain initial
condition that is you don't get to
choose how it looks at time T equals
zero that's part of the problem
statement these added constraints are
really where all of the challenge
actually lies there is a vast ocean of
function solving the PDE in the sense
that when you take their partial
derivatives the thing is going to be
equal and a sizable subset of that ocean
satisfies the right boundary conditions
when Joseph Fourier solved this problem
in 1822 his key contribution was to gain
control of this ocean turning all of the
right knobs and dials so as to be able
to select from it the particular
solution fitting a given initial
condition we can think of his solution
as being broken down into three
fundamental observations number one
certain sine waves offer a really simple
solution to this equation number two if
you know multiple solutions the sum of
these functions is also a solution and
number three most surprisingly any
function can be expressed as a sum of
sine waves well a pedantic mathematician
might point out that there are some
pathological exceptions certain weird
functions where this isn't true but
basically any distribution that you
would come across in practice including
discontinuous ones can be written as a
sum of sine waves potentially infinitely
many and if you've ever heard of Fourier
series you've at least heard of this
last idea and if so maybe you've
wondered why on earth would anyone care
about breaking down a function as
some of sine waves well in many
applications sine waves are nicer to
deal with than anything else and
differential equations offers us a
really nice context where you can see
how that plays out for our heat equation
when you write a function as a sum of
these waves the relatively clean second
derivatives makes it easy to solve the
heat equation for each one of them and
as you'll see a sum of solutions to this
equation
gives us another solution and so in turn
that will give us a recipe for solving
the heat equation for any complicated
distribution as an initial state here
let's dig into that first step why
exactly would sign waves play nicely
with the heat equation to avoid messy
constants let's start simple and say
that the temperature function at time T
equals zero is simply sine of X where X
describes the point on the rod
yes the idea of a-rod's temperature just
happening to look like sine of X varying
around whatever temperature our
conventions arbitrarily label a zero is
clearly absurd but in math you should
always be happy to play with examples
that are idealized potentially well
beyond the point of being realistic
because they can offer a good first step
in the direction of something more
general and hence more realistic
the right-hand side of this heat
equation asks about the second
derivative of our function how much our
temperature distribution curves as you
move along space the derivative of sine
of X is cosine of X whose derivative in
turn is negative sine of X the amount
that wave curves is in a sense equal and
opposite to its height at each point
so at least at the time T equals zero
this has the peculiar effect that each
point changes its temperature at a rate
proportional to the temperature of the
point itself with the same
proportionality constant across all
points so after some tiny time step
everything scales down by the same
factor and after that it's still the
same sine curve shape just scale down a
bit so the same logic applies and the
next time step would scale it down
uniformly again and this applies just as
well in the limit as the size of these
time steps approaches zero so unlike
other temperature distributions sine
waves are peculiar in that they'll get
scaled down uniformly looking like some
constant times sine of X for all times T
now when you see that the rate at which
some value changes is proportional to
that value itself your mind should burn
with the thought of an exponential and
if it's not or if you're a little rusty
on the idea of taking derivatives of
Exponential's or what makes the number e
special I'd recommend you take a look at
this video the upshot is that the
derivative of e to some constant times T
is equal to that constant times itself
if the rate at which your investment
grows for example is always say 0.05
times the total value then its value
over time is going to look like e to the
0.05 times T times whatever the initial
investment was if the rate at which the
count of carbon-14 atoms and an old bone
changes is always equal to some negative
constant times that count itself then
over time that number will look
approximately like e to that negative
constant times T times whatever the
initial count was so when you look at
our heat equation and you know that for
a sine wave the right-hand side is going
to be negative alpha times the
temperature function itself hopefully it
wouldn't be too surprising to propose
that the solution is to scale down by a
factor of e to the negative alpha T here
go ahead and check the partial
derivatives the proposed function of X
and T is sine of X times e to the
negative alpha T taking the second
partial derivative with respect to X
that e to the negative alpha T term
looks like a constant it doesn't have
any X in it so it just comes along for
the ride as if it was any other constant
like 2 and the first derivative with
respect to X is cosine of X times e to
the negative alpha T likewise the second
partial derivative with respect to X
becomes negative sine of X times e to
the negative alpha T and on the flip
side if you look at the partial
derivative with respect to T that sine
of X term now looks like a constant
since it doesn't have a T in it so we
get negative alpha times e to the
negative alpha T times sine of X so
indeed this function does make the
partial differential equation true
and oh if it was only that simple this
narrative flow could be so nice
we would just beeline directly to the
delicious Fourier series conclusion
sadly nature is not so nice knocking us
off onto an annoying but highly
necessary detour here's the thing even
if nature were to somehow produce a
temperature distribution on this rod
which looks like this perfect sine wave
the exponential decay is not actually
how it would evolve assuming that no
heat flows in or out of the rod here's
what that evolution would actually look
like the points on the left are heated
up a little at first and those on the
right are cooled down by their neighbors
to the interior in fact let me give you
an even simpler solution to the PDE
which fails to describe actual heat flow
a straight line that is the temperature
function will be some nonzero constant
times X and never change over time the
second partial derivative with respect
to X is indeed zero I mean there is no
curvature and it's partial derivative
with respect to time is also zero since
it never changes over time
and yet if I throw this into the
simulator it does actually change over
time slowly approaching a uniform
temperature at the mean value what's
going on here is that the simulation I'm
using treats the two boundary points of
the rod differently from how it treats
all the others which is a more accurate
reflection of what would actually happen
in nature if you'll recall from the last
video the intuition for where that
second derivative with respect to X
actually came from was rooted in having
each point tend towards the average
value of its two neighbors on either
side but at the boundary there is no
neighbor to one side if we went back to
thinking of the discrete version
modeling only finitely many points on
this rod you could have each boundary
point simply tend towards its one
neighbor at a rate proportional to their
difference as we do this for higher and
higher resolutions notice how pretty
much immediately after the clock starts
our distribution looks flat at either of
those two boundary points
in fact in the limiting case as these
finer and finer discretized setups
approach a continuous curve the slope of
our curve at the boundary will be zero
for all times after the start
one way this is often described is that
the slope at any given point is
proportional to the rate of heat flow at
that point so if you want to model the
restriction that no heat flows into or
out of the rod the slope at either end
will be zero that's somewhat hand wavy
and incomplete I know so if you want the
fuller details I've left links and
resources in the description taking the
example of a straight line whose slope
at the boundary points is decidedly not
zero as soon as the clock starts those
boundary values will shift in phantasmal
II such that the slope there suddenly
becomes zero and remains that way
through the remainder of the evolution
in other words finding a function
satisfying the heat equation itself is
not enough it must also satisfy the
property that it's flat at each of those
end points for all x greater than zero
phrased more precisely the partial
derivative with respect to X of our
temperature function at zero T and at LT
must be zero for all times T greater
than zero where L is the length of the
rod this is an example of a boundary
condition and pretty much any time that
you have to solve a partial differential
equation in practice there will also be
some boundary condition hanging along
for the ride which demands just as much
attention as the PDE itself all of this
may make it feel like we've gotten
nowhere but the function which is a sine
wave in space and an exponential decay
in time actually gets us quite close
we just need to tweak it a little bit so
that it's flat at both end points first
off notice that we could just as well
use a cosine function instead of a sine
I mean it's the same wave it's just
shifted and phased by a quarter of the
period which would make it flat at x
equals zero as we want the second
derivative of cosine of X is also
negative 1 times itself so for all the
same reasons as before the product
cosine of x times e to the negative
alpha T still satisfies the PDE
to make sure that it also satisfies the
boundary condition on that right side
we're going to adjust the frequency of
the wave however that will affect the
second derivative since higher frequency
waves curve more sharply and lower
frequency one's curve more gently
changing the frequency means introducing
some constant say Omega multiplied by
the input of this function a higher
value of Omega means the wave oscillates
more quickly
since as you increase X the input to the
cosine increases more rapidly
taking the derivative with respect to X
we still get negative sign but the chain
rule tells us to multiply that Omega on
the outside and similarly the second
derivative will still be negative cosine
but now with Omega squared this means
that the right-hand side of our equation
has now picked up this Omega squared
term so to balance things out on the
left-hand side the exponential decay
part should have an additional Omega
squared term up top
unpacking what that actually means
should feel intuitive for a temperature
function filled with sharper curves it
decays more quickly towards an
equilibrium and evidently it does this
quadratically for instance doubling the
frequency results in an exponential
decay four times as fast
if the length of the rod is L then the
lowest frequency where that rightmost
point of the distribution will be flat
is when Omega is equal to PI divided by
L
see that way as x increases up to the
value L the input of our cosine
expression goes up to PI which is half
the period of a cosine wave finding all
the other frequencies which satisfy this
boundary condition is sort of like
finding harmonics you essentially go
through all the whole number multiples
of this base frequency PI over L
in fact even multiplying it by zero
works since that gives us a constant
function which is indeed a valid
solution boundary condition in all and
with that we're off the bumpy boundary
condition detour and back onto the
freeway moving forward were equipped
with an infinite family of functions
satisfying both the PDE and the pesky
boundary condition things are definitely
looking more intricate now but it all
stems from the one basic observation
that a function which looks like a sine
curve in space and an exponential decay
in time fits this equation relating
second derivatives in space with first
derivatives in time and of course your
formulas should start to look more
intricate you're solving a genuinely
hard problem this actually makes for a
pretty good stopping point so let's call
it an end here and in the next video
we'll look at how to use this infinite
family to construct a more general
solution to any of you worried about
dwelling too much on a single example in
a series that's meant to give a general
overview of differential equations it's
worth emphasizing that many of the
considerations which pop up here are
frequent themes throughout the field
first off the fact that we modeled the
boundary with its own special rule while
the main differential equation only
characterized the interior is a very
regular theme and a pattern well worth
getting used to especially in the
context of PDEs also take note of how
what we're doing is breaking down a
general situation into simpler idealized
cases this strategy comes up all the
time and it's actually quite common for
these simpler cases to look like some
mixture of sine curves and Exponential's
that's not at all unique to the heat
equation and as time goes on we're going
to get a deeper feel for why that's true
you